so on sunday super smash bros melee pro
hungrybox tweeted out a picture of his
prize for placing fifth at ceo 2022's
melee tournament
a whole 75 dollars this kick started a
massive conversation about melee prize
bowl about whether or not to should pay
out more or if top players should just
shut up about this whole thing so let me
explain what's going on about why hbox
got so little for top eight one of the
biggest tournaments of the year and why
we all need to stop having this
conversation every few months
hey folks before we get into the video i
want to ask you to please sub to the
channel and turn on notifications and if
you haven't done it yet head over to
twitch.tv score esports and throw us a
follow there subs help a lot here and
follow us help a lot there we appreciate
whatever you got for us okay so this
past weekend ceo 2022 went down and it
had a pretty sick melee tournament magi
had a sick run cementing her as one of
the most exciting players in melee right
now plup made the pup club proud by
bouncing back with incredible 6-0
winning grand finals but all anybody
could talk about on twitter after the
fact was hungrybox like i said earlier
on sunday after the tournament ended
hungrybox tweeted out a picture of the
envelope containing his prize replacing
fifth a whole 75 us dollars obviously
when you compare that to what you could
be getting for fifth place in some other
games major tournaments it looks pretty
low but to be honest it's not that crazy
for melee tournaments if you don't play
fighting games most tournaments work
like this everybody pays an entry fee
which is usually ten dollars that fee
goes into a pot which is paid out to top
eight the majority of the money goes to
the person who placed first while a
smaller amount of the money goes to the
person who tied for eighth there are a
handful of tournaments that have pot
bonuses which is when someone throws in
some money to make sure the top eight
makes extra cash but those are really
rare in melee companies like capcom and
bandai will throw in money for street
fighter and tekken tournaments to drum
up interest but nintendo pretty much
always ignores melee tournaments so ceo
2022 had 224 entrants and at 10 a person
that's a two thousand two hundred and
forty dollar prize pool which roughly
shakes out to seventy five dollars for
fifth for the record club got around one
thousand one hundred and twenty bucks or
half the prize pool hungrybox would have
known that math from the moment
registration ended he knew since the
second the brackets closed how much he
stood to earn from winning the
tournament
and yet the tweet happened anyway oh
look i am not upset at hbox for wanting
more money for putting in work and
literally doing his job all weekend i'm
sure that 75 dollars feels like a slap
in the face damn and for some folks that
75 dollars was doubly insulting because
ceo is on the panda cup a new super
smash bros league organized by panda
gaming in association with nintendo some
people were hoping when the circuit was
announced that nintendo's involvement
would lead to higher prize pools at
events other than the finals but that
hasn't happened yet now to be fair
hungrybox is one of those lucky players
who doesn't need to win a bunch of money
from this tournament he's on team liquid
he's probably paid a salary he has
successful twitch and youtube channels
fact the matter is most of the people
who came to play in ceo came from out of
town and lost money on the event but
they didn't go because they were
expecting to make a ton of money playing
melee they went because they wanted to
test their skills and have fun hanging
out with their friends at a tournament
hungrybox is one of the lucky few that
gets to make money playing melee already
personally i wish that anybody could
make a living doing whatever they wanted
to like playing melee for example but
unfortunately
not the world we live in look melee
isn't most esports it is a children's
party game from 2001 that has beyond all
odds cultivated a dedicated competitive
fan base who love the game more than
anything csgo has millions of players
who are engaged in the competitive scene
league of legends is one of the biggest
games on the planet riot wants to make
sure that valerian is a hit that lasts
forever and all of these games make
their company's money hand over fist
with skin sales which is why those
companies support their esports scenes
nintendo hasn't seen ascent from melee
fans in two decades not to mention the
fact that the competitive smash scene is
a minuscule fraction of the overall
smash audience even smash ultimate a
game that nintendo was still making dlc
for as of last year is not getting
supported with pop bonuses nintendo just
doesn't care about competitive smash
whether they should or shouldn't is
irrelevant
they don't in fact sometimes nintendo
actively works against the smash
community yo ninja should you borrow
from me or something when the [__] are
you helping out the smash community all
right listen bro i've been waiting
the streets are wondering that was on
nintendo not me you know what the worst
thing is i believe
it's 100 percent absolutely okay dude
all i wanted to do was just
was to create a massive tournament and
all i wanted i literally wanted to just
juice evo
like
500k
but i wanted to do it
i know
i'm not going to tilt that button
85 percent worse
there's ghosting and there's
and so smash prize pools are gonna
continue to languish at least under the
current model well like i said earlier
this conversation crops up once every
couple of months when a pro is
frustrated by the pittance they got for
playing melee and it's not a new thing
we've had these conversations literally
dozens of times for years i think
everyone agrees that we're not expecting
tournament organizers to just open up
their wallets and fork over thousands of
dollars to top players just for playing
the game
we'd never get tournaments again it
would be horrible but the fact of the
matter is melee prize pools do seem to
be shrinking as less people enter
tournaments in the post-covered era so
let's talk about some solutions ones
that don't involve whining about
nintendo first there's crowdfunding
which has worked to great effect in the
melee scene in the past but does come
with its own issues seat smash summit
crowdfunds their prize goals leading to
each summit event having some of the
highest prize pools in the scene tweek
got 47
739 dollars for winning ultimate summit
3 the highest single prize in smash
history and literally 12 000
more than the entire prize pool for evo
2019 smash ultimate tournament the
problem if you can call it one is that
summit events are exclusive these are
invite-only tournaments a good player
can be voted in but it's not an open
bracket that means that anybody who
doesn't already have a sponsor or is
willing to lose a bunch of money
traveling around the u.s to make their
name is out of luck when it comes to
getting a crack at these massive prize
pools and while crowdfunding can result
in high prize pools they are ultimately
at the mercy of community interest melee
smack summit 11 had a 153
372 dollar crowdfunded prize pool smash
them at 12 went down to 56 951 dollars
and smashed them at 13 went all the way
down to 29 808
those are still quite high by melee
standards but they're not going to
provide the kind of lucrative
eye-popping payouts you see in other
games so what else can the melee scene
do if they want to put more money into
top players pockets well tournament
organizers could raise the entry fees
from 10 to 20
this solution has been floated by top
players in the past and look it would
have literally double all prize pools by
having the community chip in a little
more on the surface that makes sense
after all it's just 10
and inflation has really changed the
value of the pot without the entry fee
being changed to reflect that but at the
same time critics of racing entry fees
have noted that on top of your entry fee
you're probably also paying for hotels
registration travel food going from 10
to 20 could be the straw that breaks the
camel's back when it comes to someone
choosing to enter a tournament or not
and what's better someone entering and
putting ten dollars in the pot or
someone staying home and putting zero in
the pot
look there's no easy answer here top
players like hungrybox and elephant have
said plenty of times that the reason
they make such a stink about prize
payouts is because they don't want the
next generation of melee players to be
discouraged from getting into an already
incredibly inaccessible game and
honestly i think they're right after all
if you're a new up-and-coming player and
you grind your ass off to make top 8 at
a major and you don't even make enough
money to cover your registration let
alone your hotel fee
that's gonna feel really bad and might
discourage you from playing again unless
you're crazy passionate about the game
but that's the thing melee fans are
crazy passionate all fighting game
players are if we wanted big prize pools
we would have played fortnite when it
was competitively relevant nobody ever
gotten to melee to get rich obviously i
don't want anybody to starve playing
melee i want everybody to do whatever
they love and earn enough money to make
a living and if that means playing a
children's party game from 2001 go for
it that's awesome
but we do have to acknowledge that there
is a financial reward in place for being
good at the game it's called getting
signed to an esports team obviously that
doesn't happen to everyone but the fact
that melee doesn't have giant piles of
money being poured into the scene from
who knows where is what keeps the game
sustainable and why it's going to last a
lot longer than every other esport on
the planet i bet you that if valve
decided to say [__] it to cs go tomorrow
and cancel the majors a lot of cs go
pros would stop playing if riot [__]
canned all their regional leagues
competitive league would all but dry up
but fighting games would survive all
that melee has survived all that it
doesn't need big companies or huge prize
fools propping it up it's awesome and a
privilege that top players get to make a
living playing this game but that's
exactly what it is bigger prize bowls
might give melee another pop of big time
relevance the way it's had a few times
in the last decade but i don't think
they're going to change the long-term
health of the game maybe one day entry
fees go up and prize pools increase
maybe one day nintendo shows up and adds
a million dollar pop bonus maybe one day
all of that goes away but at the end of
it all there are still gonna be two
people sitting in front of a shitty crt
monitor holding gamecube controllers
playing for 75 dollars
and that's beautiful
do you think there's a top league of
legends player who would just call
themselves league of legends that'd be
awesome i wanna i wanna change my league
of legends id my summoner id to league
of legends league of legends was born in
1994 and they started playing the game
league of legends released in 2009. they
became one of the greatest league of
legends players on the planet and league
of legends didn't stop there
but there but then in april 2020
valorant came out